you have a beard therefore you must be
wise do you have advice for young people
high school college
about how to carve their path through
life how to have a life
uh a career
that's successful that they can be proud
of or a life they can be proud of man
see this is what kind of this is what
sucks
about
my life is that it's been very
random and very spontaneous so
unfortunately i don't get
that thing where i could be like well
here's what i did yeah because it's like
i don't like i
i inherited
twelve thousand dollars from my
grandmother here's what you do kids you
inherit twelve thousand dollars when
your grandmother dies and then you need
to be dumb enough to think that that
twelve thousand dollars is gonna help
you live in la for a year so then what
you do is you move to la with twelve
thousand dollars
and you find a shitty
place that you live at and then you use
that money to buy acid and synthesizers
and then you run out of the money and
then you
and then you have to get a job
and so then because you think it'll be
fun to work at a comedy club
you get a job at the comedy store and
then
you know that's how it happened for me
and none of there wasn't i never was
never had the confidence to be like oh
i'm going to be a stand-up comedian no
way i just thought it'd be cool to work
in that building i thought the building
looked cool and so
but then like because like you work at
the comedy store you get stage time it's
there
it's the reason like yours you work
there is at least in those days because
it's not like they're paying like a [ __ ]
ton of money for you to answer phones at
a comedy club
and so
you know i started going on stage and
then like i just got lucky
because rogan saw me have like a very
rare good set i didn't know he was in
the room or out of bombed you know and
then like because he thought i was funny
and he liked talking to me he started
taking me on the road with him
and then you know so i don't know man i
i think uh
was there an element to there's a
beautiful weirdness to you
as a human being
was there was there uh
like a pressure to conform ever to hide
yourself
from the world
or or the the twelve thousand dollars
and the ass would give you the
confidence you needed to be yourself no
no i don't like i instill i'm no i i
think
sure there's that pressure and like you
know
whenever you're you're beginning to
really differentiate from your parents
but then you go back to hang out with
your parents you'll you'll you can feel
that it's not like they even want you to
conform but you'll just you could slip
into that whatever that was so i
remember that when i would go back and
like
visit them and stuff and surely
conformity or the pressure to like
not be individual or whatever it's it's
everywhere man do you think you made
your parents proud
no no no no well i think that um
when my mom died
i i felt successful in the sense that i
was
able to
support my i was i was making money from
doing stand-up in my i didn't need help
i was like as i was supporting myself
with art and doing good what i thought
was great then so
and i think she like had because she had
witnessed
me literally failing i mean which is by
the way i think part of if you want to
be
an artist or successful you kind of have
to fail like they're if if
and if there was a guaranteed
route from
sucking to not sucking or from
like
the neophyte phase of whatever the art
form is and you know some intermediary
phase then i think a lot more people
would do it but
there really is no guarantees in it
especially the stand-up comedy it's like
you'd have to be a maniac to want to
think that that's going to work out for
you you have to so you're going to
there are obviously exceptions but
for me it was like
a long slog
you know and that's scary for a mom so
but that being said
when she was
dying like she did recognize that i was
like not slogging anymore and she did
say
she said you did it
and
that's cool but
and you know i would love for her to see
me now like now it'd be way cooler but
maybe she does i don't know she's
listening to your podcast elsewhere in
the other in the in the bar now
yeah however long that lasts
reconfiguring the whole process to start
again
um you as a father now how did that
change you
yeah that's the big change man that's
the thing you made you made a few
biological
i reproduce yeah i made biological
entities i mean like what came in my
wife let's face it like i would love to
say i made them but the womb whipped
them up um
but
it is the
yeah it's the best it's i've never
experienced anything like it
before it is the
as far as i'm concerned the greatest
thing that has ever happened to me and
and that's why i was able to answer your
nietzsche question with like hell yes
[ __ ] yes that's great i get to be around
my kids again i'll always be around my
kids always be around my children
that's incredible that's the joy so like
so for me
the part of myself that used to torture
myself more specific like around like my
mom dying feeling like i wasn't that
there enough for her wishing that i had
spent more time with her
wishing i'd spent more time with my dad
wishing that like
you know looking back at like how like i
was just so desperately trying to evade
the fact that she
was dying
uh and through and in that evasion
successfully like distanced myself from
her and like
in ways that i really wish i hadn't uh
i'm just saying that because like it's
one of my regrets it's like a big regret
i have a lot of literal regrets but
that's a big one and so
when you have
kids
you look back
at everything you did
and you think like [ __ ]
if i'd gone left at that point instead
of right
if i had eaten who knows what if i'd
eaten like a turkey sandwich
when my balls were
creating the [ __ ] that was going to make
my kids would i have a different kid
would this being not exist in my life
like you start looking at everything and
you realize like
oh thank god thank god for every single
thing that happened to me because it all
led up to this and oh for me that is the
that's
that it's like
it frees you
in this it liberates you because you
realize like oh wow as clumsy and
selfish and
and at times rotten
if i as i've been in my life
that did not impede
the universe
at all from allowing this these two
beautiful
beings to exist in the world so maybe
all of it enabled all of it
like a concert
perfectly led up to that
little beautiful moment
is there ways
you would like to be a better father
oh yeah for sure absolutely i there's a
there's an actual
i read something in a book it's called
good enough the mantra for a parent
good enough because when you are in the
presence of something you love
more than
you've ever experienced love
you
you want to be perfect like you want to
be i can't i gotta work man i gotta go
on the road i've gotta work i gotta
support the family so i that means i
have to work like
i work you know you know what it's like
having a podcast you [ __ ] work man
and
uh
you know it's a full-time job because
you know i do stand-up too and all the
other stuff so i feel
so sometimes i i feel like oh my god i
want to spend more time with him like i
should be spending more time with him
but then also
i want to create i want to work i i like
being like
the provider
so
that's something i i feel guilty about
you know right now you're struggling how
to balance that correctly
and meanwhile time just marches on
it just goes it goes
and all of this
will be forgotten
both you and i
but forgotten
in time that's what i say to them every
time i'm putting them to bed
we
we will be lost in the sands of time you
know that i bet you know this poem you
know that poem ozzy mandius yes
can i read you a plot
okay
let's let's end our conversation in the
poem i love it it's by
pierce by shelley probably
mispronouncing the name
but i think the right way to pronounce
it thank you thank you
um
i'm ozzy mandius i met a traveler from
an antique land who said
two vast and trunkless legs of stone
stand in the desert
near them on the sand
half sunk as shattered visage lies whose
frown and wrinkled lip and sneer of cold
command
tell that its sculptor well those
passions read which yet survive stamped
on these lifeless things the hand that
mocked them and the heart that fed and
on the pedestal these words appear
my name is ozymandias king of kings
look on my works ye mighty and despair
nothing beside remains around the decay
of that colossal wreck
boundless and bare the lone and level
sands stretch far away
all gone
behold the king look at my works ye
mighty and despair and despair
uh even though we'll be forgotten in the
sands of time duncan i'm just so glad
that you exist and you put so much love
into the world over the past many years
that i've gotten a chance to enjoy it by
being your fan and
thank you so much for continuing that
and for sharing a bit of love with me
today can we be friends
let's be friends in real time in the
real world in 3d space nothing is real
but yes in this particular slice of the
multi-dimensional world we live in
it will be an honor and a pleasure thank
you for having me on your show love you
duncan i love you thank you lex
you